This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真实。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析心理韧性、健身以及在这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
让自己经历一些磨难，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《2%》。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，拆解当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时光的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我不认为还有比这更重要的年份对黑人来说了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行一些在其他任何地方都不太安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人背负着盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要使用它。请在AHA Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃卡德被指控让人生下双胞胎。但怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吧？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来揭开一个令人不安的模式。还有两名经历过同样事情的男性。格雷格，一个女同性恋者。迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what
我的大脑被震撼了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。
he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spike, and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode. Today, we are talking about one of the most debilitating and painful experiences I think a person can go through. Betrayal. Not just heartbreak, not just disappointment, not just a fight, but the moment someone you trust,
他应得的。我们总是说要相信你的闺蜜。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》。大家好。我是杰玛·斯派克，欢迎回到《The Psychology of Your 20s》，这是一个我们讨论20多岁时最大的变化、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。很高兴你能回来收听新的一集。今天，我们要谈论我认为一个人所能经历的最令人衰弱和痛苦的经历之一。背叛。不仅仅是心碎，不仅仅是失望，不仅仅是一场争吵，而是当你信任的人，
trusted proves themselves capable of hurting you in a manner in a way that you never imagined. The moment really that somebody takes everything that you have given them. Time, kindness, energy, love, trust. And they say, this means nothing to me. I'm going to go and do what I want anyways. It is a pain like no other because betrayal doesn't just change how you relate and how you see that person. It changes how you see everyone. changes how you approach all future relationships, platonic, familial, romantic or otherwise,
曾经信任的人，证明他们有能力以你从未想象过的方式伤害你。那一刻，真的，有人拿走了你给他们的一切。时间、善良、精力、爱、信任。然后他们说，这对我不意味着什么。无论如何，我都要去做我想做的事。这是一种无与伦比的痛苦，因为背叛不仅改变了你与那个人的关系以及你看待那个人的方式。它改变了你看待所有人的方式。改变了你处理所有未来关系的方式，无论是柏拉图式的、家庭的、浪漫的还是其他的，
and it changes how you see yourself. There is a science, a psychology to this pain that really helps capture how earth-shattering moments like this can be and how they influence our psychology and who we go forward as people. So today we're going to lay it all out there from the response of your nervous system to betrayal trauma theory, betrayal, minus the role of shattered assumptions, but then also the seven stages of healing from betrayal and the silver lining, the optimism that we're going to end with, that betrayal is something you can recover from. So we have a lot to cover today. If you have been through this, if you are struggling with the recent betrayal, I hope this episode helps you, even in the tiniest of ways.
它改变了你看待自己的方式。这种痛苦背后有一种科学，一种心理学，它确实有助于捕捉像这样天崩地裂的时刻是多么严重，以及它们如何影响我们的心理和我们未来成为什么样的人。所以今天我们要把一切都摆出来，从你的神经系统对背叛创伤理论的反应，背叛，减去破碎假设的角色，但也包括从背叛中治愈的七个阶段，以及我们将以之结束的一线希望，即乐观情绪，背叛是可以从中恢复的。所以我们今天有很多内容要讲。如果你经历过这些，如果你正在与最近的背叛作斗争，我希望这一集能帮助你，哪怕是一点点。
Without further ado, let's get into it. When you truly start to think about betrayal and when you start to look for betrayal, you really do begin to realize just how many forms it comes in. I think our mind often goes to the typical things. Like at least my mind, when I think of betrayal, I think of cheating, I think of infidelity, I think of a friend lying to you, a friend sharing a secret. There are so many other forms of betrayal that we don't talk about. We don't talk about the promises that a boss makes that they're never going to fulfill. We don't talk about a parent dismissing what you went through with their. them or in your childhood, or favoritism for one child over the other.
废话不多说，让我们开始吧。当你真正开始思考背叛，当你开始寻找背叛时，你真的会开始意识到它有多少种形式。我想我们的思维通常会转向典型的事情。至少我的思维是这样，当我想到背叛时，我会想到出轨，想到不忠，想到朋友对你撒谎，朋友分享秘密。还有很多我们不谈论的背叛形式。我们不谈论老板做出的永远不会兑现的承诺。我们不谈论父母忽视你在他们身边或童年时期所经历的事情，或者对一个孩子偏心于另一个孩子。
We don't talk about somebody taking your idea and exploiting it, somebody making promises and never coming through for you. These are all acts of betrayal. Finally, I think we don't talk about institutional betrayal enough and betrayal that can emerge on on a macro level, from a school, from a workplace, from a medical organization, from the police force. Like a lot of times, like the news will spotlight these things. And we don't often consider the people that are behind, there is still relationships there that betrayal has occurred within. And just because it's between somebody in an institution doesn't mean that it's not an interpersonal social hurt. There is this huge case in Australia at the moment of, I think it's over a hundred
我们不谈论有人窃取你的想法并加以利用，有人做出承诺却从未为你实现。这些都是背叛行为。最后，我认为我们对制度性背叛谈论得不够多，这种背叛可能在宏观层面上出现，来自学校、工作场所、医疗机构、警察部队。就像很多时候，新闻会聚焦这些事情。而我们往往不考虑背后的人，那里仍然存在着背叛发生的关系。仅仅因为它发生在某人和一个机构之间，并不意味着它不是一种人际社会伤害。目前澳大利亚有一个巨大的案例，我想有超过一百名
women. They had endometriosis and they went to this one doctor to get surgery. And he would basically perform very severe, very aggressive, very unnecessary incisions and surgeries. These women didn't need. He'd often make their lives worse, and he would cover it up. His staff, the hospital he worked at, covered it up, right? How awful is that? And it's awful, as it is awful in all cases of betrayal because of trust, because trust was there to begin with. The best quote I've heard about betrayal is the most tragic thing about it. is that it never comes from an enemy. You know, these women trusted this man because he was a doctor, because he seemed to listen to them, because he said he'd take care of them. In all cases of betrayal,
女性。她们患有子宫内膜异位症，她们去找这位医生做手术。他基本上会进行非常严重、非常激进、非常不必要的手术。这些女性根本不需要。他经常让她们的生活变得更糟，而且他会掩盖它。他的员工，他工作的医院，掩盖了它，对吧？这有多可怕？这很可怕，因为它在所有背叛案例中都很可怕，因为信任，因为信任从一开始就存在。关于背叛我听过的最好的名言是它最悲剧的一点。就是它永远不会来自敌人。你知道，这些女性信任这个男人，因为他是医生，因为他似乎在倾听她们，因为他说他会照顾她们。在所有背叛案例中，
this is the underlying thing, you don't think this person is capable of doing this to you, either because they claim to care about you, they claim to love you, they were meant to protect you, they were an authority figure, they were a parent, and the nature of that relationship, like, allowed you to let your guard down, and that is what they saw as an opportunity to then let you down. Someone thought, in all instances of betrayal, your basic needs are less important than my wants. You know, their desire to feel significant, to get what they want, to have people like them, to be entertained any number of things means more to them than your basic humanity and the respect that you deserve. This points to a very critical thing about betrayal that I just have to
这是根本所在，你不认为这个人有能力对你做这种事，要么是因为他们声称关心你，他们声称爱你，他们本应保护你，他们是一个权威人物，他们是父母，而那种关系的本质，让你放下了戒备，而这正是他们看到的让你失望的机会。有人认为，在所有背叛的例子中，你的基本需求不如我的欲望重要。你知道，他们想要感到重要、得到他们想要的、让人们喜欢他们、被娱乐等等，这些对他们来说比你基本的人性和你应得的尊重更重要。这指出了关于背叛的一个非常关键的事情，我必须
to mention, like, it's close to the beginning of this episode as possible. The severity of the outcome of the betrayal does not matter. No matter how large the consequence is, it doesn't matter because the damage is done. Like, again, yeah, the consequences of betrayal don't need to be this big and dramatic thing for a betrayal to be harmful. You know, you might tell somebody a secret that doesn't really have any earth-shattering consequences. but it's still extremely hurtful at the same time to have it revealed and for that trust to be broken.
提到，尽可能靠近这一集的开头。背叛结果的严重性并不重要。无论后果有多大，都不重要，因为伤害已经造成了。就像，再说一次，是的，背叛的后果不需要是这种巨大而戏剧性的事情，背叛才会造成伤害。你知道，你可能会告诉某人一个秘密，这并没有什么天崩地裂的后果。但被揭露出来，那种信任被打破，仍然是非常痛苦的。
Everything from moments like that to massive things all rest on the same thing. There is a loss of emotional safety that is almost impossible to come back from and not just with them but with the people who remind you of them later on and the relationships that have a similar energy to them later on. I think that's the reason we see betrayal depicted in so many. like great works of art, like literature and movies and poems and plays and TV. One of my favorite books, literally, The Secret History, is essentially just a psychological deep dive into betrayal.
从那一刻到巨大的事情，一切都基于同一件事。有一种情感安全感的丧失，几乎是不可能恢复的，不仅是与他们，而且与那些后来让你想起他们的人，以及后来具有类似能量的关系。我认为这就是为什么我们在这么多艺术作品中看到背叛的描绘，比如文学、电影、诗歌、戏剧和电视。我最喜欢的书之一，《秘密历史》，本质上就是对背叛的心理深度剖析。
And the reason we see it so often is because we are drawn to depictions like this, the same way that we are drawn to horror movies. You know, betrayal is one of those things that scares us, but also fascinates us the most because of how much it is perceived as such a threat emotionally and psychologically. It terrifies us. So let's examine this a little bit further. If you are currently reeling from somebody in your life doing something absolutely terrible to you, why does it hurt so much?
我们之所以经常看到它，是因为我们被这样的描绘所吸引，就像我们被恐怖电影所吸引一样。你知道，背叛是那些既让我们害怕，又最让我们着迷的事情之一，因为它在情感和心理上被视为一种巨大的威胁。它让我们感到恐惧。所以让我们进一步探讨一下。如果你目前正因为生命中某人对你做了极其糟糕的事情而感到痛苦，为什么它会如此痛苦？
What I wish more people knew is that being betrayed does and can leave, long-term psychological wounds that have been shown, that have been examined in study after study, and they don't just manifest in your emotional life, they manifest physically as well. So to understand that, we have to look at what happens, I guess, biologically, but also neurologically, when you experience betrayal, like what is happening to the network in your brain? First things first, when you experience a betrayal, like your brain's threat system activates like crazy. The discovery of betrayal is literally seen as like a threat to your safety, a threat to your survival. It's going to cost you socially, financially, in terms of safety, that triggers the amygdala.
我希望更多人知道的是，被背叛确实可以留下长期的心理创伤，这些创伤已经在研究中被反复检查过，它们不仅体现在你的情感生活中，也体现在身体上。所以要理解这一点，我们必须看看当你经历背叛时，生物学上，但也包括神经学上发生了什么，你的大脑网络中发生了什么？首先，当你经历背叛时，你大脑的威胁系统会疯狂激活。背叛的发现实际上被视为对你安全的威胁，对你生存的威胁。它会在社交、经济、安全方面让你付出代价，这会触发杏仁核。
The amygdala is just going to flood your body with adrenaline. And it's just going to try and get us to realize through whatever means possible, like something is going wrong. Often that means pushing you into like fight, flight or freeze. Essentially your body is just like, this is painful. this is a threat, how are we going to live through this? That is why, like, when people first learn about betrayal, they'll often talk about how they just felt this terrible rush, they felt shaky, numb, they felt panicked, they felt dizzy. That is your body being hit by a biological truck that is meant to protect you. Our hippocampus, you guys might know this part of the brain,
杏仁核会用肾上腺素淹没你的身体。它会试图通过任何可能的方式让我们意识到，有什么事情出错了。通常这意味着把你推向战斗、逃跑或冻结。本质上，你的身体只是觉得，这很痛苦。这是一种威胁，我们要如何活过这一关？这就是为什么，当人们第一次得知背叛时，他们经常会谈论他们感到的那种可怕的冲动，他们感到颤抖、麻木、恐慌、头晕。那是你的身体被一种旨在保护你的生物卡车撞击了。我们的海马体，你们可能知道大脑的这个部分，
it's responsible for memory and learning. This part of our brain also goes into open your hippocampus is basically responsible for deciding what is important for me to remember and what doesn't really matter. The thing is the more emotionally intense a situation or a learning experience is the deeper that our brain encodes it. This can lead to what we know in psychology as flashbulb memories. These are like vivid, intrusive recollections that feel almost stuck in time. People will talk about the moment they realized their partner of many years was lying to them. or their moment a parent betrayed them or somebody at work betrayed them 20 years later in perfect detail.
它负责记忆和学习。我们大脑的这一部分也会进入开放状态，海马体基本上负责决定什么对我来说是重要的记忆，什么并不重要。问题是，一个情况或学习经历的情感越强烈，我们大脑编码得就越深。这可能导致我们在心理学中所说的闪光灯记忆。这些就像生动、侵入性的回忆，感觉几乎被困在时间里。人们会谈论他们意识到相处多年的伴侣在欺骗他们的那一刻。或者父母背叛他们的那一刻，或者20年后在工作中背叛他们的人，细节完美。
You know, they could tell you what they were wearing, they could tell you what song was playing in the background, what cologne they could smell, what the carpet felt like beneath them. Because your brain is basically like, if we survive this, we better know how we did it because it's going to be a miracle if we did. And we better be able to remember every moment that led to our survival in case there is the next time. This is obviously a real problem for the healing stage. It's honestly so annoying because memories like this survive and stand the test of time. And that's why they continue to be difficult to recover from. Third thing that's happening in your brain, your prefrontal cortex is
你知道，他们可以告诉你他们穿什么，他们可以告诉你背景里在放什么歌，他们能闻到什么古龙水，地毯在他们脚下是什么感觉。因为你的大脑基本上是说，如果我们活下来了，我们最好知道我们是怎么做到的，因为如果我们做到了，那将是一个奇迹。而且我们最好能够记住导致我们生存的每一刻，以防下一次。这显然是治愈阶段的一个真正问题。老实说，这太烦人了，因为这样的记忆能够存活并经受住时间的考验。这就是为什么它们继续难以从中恢复。你大脑中发生的第三件事，你的前额叶皮层被
suppressed. Your rational thinking disappears because you are still in that shocked survival state. I'm sorry, I keep using the cheating example. I feel like it's just the easiest one. but say you found out that like your partner has cheated on you, you might later be like, oh my God, why did I not say what I wanted to say? Like, why did I react that way? Why wasn't I angry? Why didn't I say something? Why didn't I scream at them?
抑制了。你的理性思维消失了，因为你仍然处于那种震惊的生存状态。抱歉，我一直用出轨的例子。我觉得这只是最简单的一个。但假设你发现你的伴侣出轨了，你后来可能会想，天哪，为什么我没有说我想说的话？为什么我会有那样的反应？为什么我不生气？为什么我没有说什么？为什么我没有对他们尖叫？
Your brain didn't think to do it. The rational part of your brain that prioritized closure of that catharsis was just like prioritizing protection, not analysis. after this fades, this first wave after that fades, the first, like, true shock of the explosion hits you. This is when you really start to regain some like cognitive clarity. This is when you start talking to witnesses or people around you who were like, hey, no, that was fucked. Like, that shouldn't happen. That person was not nice to you. The pain centers of our brain now light up. you know, research has shown that emotional betrayal activates the same neural pathways as physical pain. There was a series of experiments done in 2009 showing that even when participants imagined
你的大脑没想过要这样做。你大脑中优先考虑那种宣泄的理性部分只是优先考虑保护，而不是分析。在这之后消退，第一波之后消退，爆炸的第一次真正的冲击击中你。这是你真正开始恢复一些认知清晰度的时候。这是你开始与目击者或周围的人交谈的时候，他们会说，嘿，不，那太糟糕了。那不应该发生。那个人对你不好。我们大脑的疼痛中心现在亮了起来。你知道，研究表明，情感背叛激活了与身体疼痛相同的神经通路。2009年进行了一系列实验，表明即使参与者想象
unacceptable, you know, non-consensual, terrible acts, their brains, even though it was an imagined thing, still experienced this as a real threat and it still lit up the same pain regions as when you are punched in the gut or when you break a limb. So this is when you really start to feel it. This is when you really also might start to notice excessive rumination and obsessive thoughts. Essentially, like, now, like, the data, now the information of the actors it has caught up to you. And your brain is going to start really, like, trying to review and figure out what happened. Essentially, just to restore, like, the broken narrative of our worldview, to try and find
不可接受的、非自愿的、可怕的行为，他们的大脑，尽管是想象的事情，仍然将其视为一种真正的威胁，并且它仍然像你腹部被重击或骨折时一样点亮了相同的疼痛区域。所以这是你真正开始感觉到的时候。这也是你可能开始注意到过度反刍和强迫性思维的时候。本质上，现在，数据，现在行为者的信息已经追上了你。你的大脑将开始真正地试图回顾并弄清楚发生了什么。本质上，只是为了恢复我们世界观的破碎叙事，试图找到
And like the explanation, the puzzle piece for like, why did somebody do this? Like, you want the world to make sense again. You want a logical reason as to why somebody acted this way towards you. This emotional looping of like searching, trying to find an answer, it is a form of coping. And what's ironic about this is our brain is trying to protect us. Our brain is trying to conclude the story, finds them closure. But that rumination often makes it worse because it starts encoding that memory even deeper and deeper and deeper. in short, I think this whole explanation, this neurological, biological explanation shows us that, like, betrayal is a form of trauma.
解释，拼图碎片，为什么有人会这样做？你想让世界再次变得有意义。你想要一个逻辑上的理由，为什么有人会这样对待你。这种寻找答案的情感循环，是一种应对方式。而这讽刺的是，我们的大脑试图保护我们。我们的大脑试图结束这个故事，找到解脱。但那种反刍往往使情况变得更糟，因为它开始将那种记忆编码得越来越深。简而言之，我认为整个解释，这种神经学、生物学的解释向我们展示了，背叛是一种创伤。
Betrayal is a profound loss. And it's not just one loss. That's the thing. You are losing so many things. You experience the loss of trust, like firstly, but then you also probably experience the loss of this relationship. Like, you don't want to be with them anymore or be around them anymore. You then experience the loss of the future that you imagined with that person or with those. as people, all your plans, all those opportunities, you then lose dignity, you then lose other
背叛是一种深刻的损失。而且不仅仅是一次损失。这就是问题所在。你正在失去很多东西。你经历了信任的丧失，首先，但随后你也可能经历了这段关系的丧失。你不想再和他们在一起或在他们身边了。然后你经历了你想象中与那个人或那些人在一起的未来的丧失，你所有的计划，所有那些机会，然后你失去了尊严，然后你失去了其他
relationships that were tied to that person, you then lose a loss of future safety. Like it is, how many, that's at least seven, right? It's not just that you lost the trust. Such an expansive experience of loss. Again, that is why this is trauma. That is why it is not dramatic to suggest that like this leaves long lasting emotional wounds. there is this whole theory actually called betrayal trauma theory that shows betrayal can cause even more emotional scarring than non-betrayal trauma.
与那个人有关的关系，然后你失去了未来的安全感。这是，有多少，至少七个，对吧？不仅仅是你失去了信任。如此广泛的损失体验。再说一次，这就是为什么这是创伤。这就是为什么暗示这会留下持久的情感创伤并不夸张。实际上有一个完整的理论叫做背叛创伤理论，它表明背叛甚至可以比非背叛创伤造成更多的情感创伤。
I don't always like to compare, I think it's like apples and oranges, but like there is impact there that is seen on a similar level as going to war, experience a car accident, experiencing violence. Essentially all of this is just to validate. Right. Going through this, even if somebody wasn't violent against you, even if somebody, you know, didn't do something unimaginable or didn't do something that, like, would make the newspapers, like, it still leaves lasting emotional wounds. And it still really does kind of change who you are as a person. And that's exactly what we're going to discuss as well as, as I said, how to heal from this betrayal after the short break. So stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
我不总是喜欢比较，我认为这就像苹果和橘子，但那里确实有影响，其水平与上战场、经历车祸、经历暴力相当。本质上，所有这些只是为了验证。经历这些，即使有人没有对你施暴，即使有人没有做不可想象的事情，或者没有做会登上报纸的事情，它仍然会留下持久的情感创伤。它确实在某种程度上改变了你作为一个人的本质。这正是我们将要讨论的内容，正如我所说，如何在短暂休息后从这种背叛中治愈。所以请留下来。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析心理韧性、健身以及在这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。
I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
我将与作家、研究人员和其他健康与健身专家以及更多人交谈，以超越统治健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上是炎症性的。我们错了。我们在世界上感到惊慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些磨难，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《2%》。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金的胸部吗？
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s.
或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和小金有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，拆解当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时光的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的对话，大谈80年代的快克。
To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crime. crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes.
明确地说，84年对我来说很重要，不仅仅是因为犯罪。快克。我愿意在某天谈论快克，但只是让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集。所以我开始看到有一条主线。我们现在桌上还有艾滋病。谢谢你完成那句话。是的。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience
我不认为还有比这更重要的年份对黑人来说了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师，基尔·盖恩斯。为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了我十多年来的个人经验
in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tript Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses.
在心理健康领域，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是，特里普特·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候已经做得足够了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢。
Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines,
史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得做一个好人很重要，而你活在地球上，还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对。那是两种不同的信任水平。我希望你真正成为一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，
as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app, Search learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
在我们新的播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，我们进行关于治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的IHeart Radio应用程序，搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃卡德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭示了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了一场长达数年的法庭斗争，以证明真相。
You doctored this particular test twice in someone's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Marantini.
你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吧？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来破解这个案件。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用于什么。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们揭开了一个令人不安的模式。还有两名经历过同样事情的男性。格雷格·莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges.
我的大脑被震撼了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。
This isn't over until Justice served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either.
在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。规则一，永远不要招惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也永远不要招惹她的朋友。
We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield. And in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care.
我们总是说要相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德。在《The Girlfriends》的新一季中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉就像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上？警察似乎并不关心。
So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
所以她们决定采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼不。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》。
The real long-lasting pain of betrayal is that the other person gets to move on. They get to move on. And you are the one that's left with a fundamental sense of uncertainty moving forward with your life. This uncertainty continues to like pop its nasty head up again and again in so many other situations and so many other relationships where it does not deserve to be. In fact, there was a 2024 study that systematically investigated this with over 100 and 40 participants who had experienced partner betrayal, trauma, and the study found that in nearly every single case,
背叛带来的真正持久的痛苦是，另一个人可以继续前进。他们可以继续前进。而你却是那个在生活中留下基本不确定感的人。这种不确定性继续在许多其他情况和许多其他关系中一次又一次地冒出它丑陋的头，而它本不应该出现在那里。事实上，2024年的一项研究系统地调查了这一点，有超过140名经历过伴侣背叛、创伤的参与者，研究发现，在几乎每一个案例中，
individuals had lower self-esteem, they had an increased sense of future relationship anxiety, an increased sense of hypervigilance, and they almost, I think it was all of them, found it harder to imagine ever trusting anybody ever again. I think the reason why this is is because almost all at once, when somebody betrays us, we are forced to shift our perspective on what people are capable of. It's not to say we were ignorant before, not at all, but we kind of all like to live
个人的自尊心较低，他们对未来关系的焦虑感增加，警惕性增加，而且他们几乎，我想是所有人，发现很难想象再信任任何人。我认为原因在于，几乎同时，当有人背叛我们时，我们被迫改变对人们能力的看法。这并不是说我们以前很无知，根本不是，但我们都喜欢生活
with the assumption that people are as kind as we are, as are as empathetic as we are, and that if somebody loves somebody else or somebody cares for somebody else or makes a promise, they will not break that promise, they will not hurt them. That is like the social contract that we need for society and for relationships to thrive and to continue. And so for that contract to suddenly be revealed as incorrect, jeopardizes like all that we think we know about humanity and how we think humans operate. The social psychologist Ronnie Janoff-Bulman, I think the name was, she calls this exact experience the shattered assumption experience. It is a phenomena where something traumatic occurs and you cannot readily assimilate that into the previous
在假设人们像我们一样善良，像我们一样有同理心，如果有人爱别人或关心别人或做出承诺，他们就不会打破那个承诺，他们就不会伤害他们。这就是社会和关系繁荣和持续所需的社会契约。因此，那个契约突然被揭示为不正确，危及了我们认为我们所知道的关于人类的一切以及我们认为人类如何运作的一切。社会心理学家罗尼·贾诺夫-布尔曼，我想名字是这个，她称这种确切的体验为破碎假设体验。这是一种现象，当创伤性事件发生时，你无法轻易将其同化到之前的
worldview that you held. And that creates a lot of psychological and emotional chaos and confusion. Essentially, the shattered assumptions theory is that in that exact moment when we realize when the curtain is lifted, our whole narrative about other people and their behavior is like disturbed in an instance. And the reaction this creates in us also has an it's called systemic mistrust, and it also creates systemic vigilance or hypervigilance. Basically, it creates this reaction where now we question everything, even things that don't need to be questioned. We assume the worst than everybody.
世界观中。这会产生大量的心理和情感混乱。本质上，破碎假设理论是，在那一刻，当我们意识到，当帷幕被拉开时，我们关于他人及其行为的整个叙事在瞬间就被扰乱了。这在我们身上产生的反应也有一个名字，叫做系统性不信任，它也产生系统性警惕或过度警惕。基本上，它创造了这种反应，现在我们质疑一切，即使是不需要质疑的事情。我们假设每个人都是最坏的。
Like, we cannot help it. We don't ever want to feel this way again. We don't ever want to be hurt again. And that makes relationships in the future really, really hard. Another big thing is that we don't just find it hard to trust others because of these shattered of assumptions, we find it hard to trust ourselves and I actually think this is the more insidious part. Although you may rationally know and I will happily tell you, everybody may tell you this is not your fault. Nobody asked to be betrayed. It's just not your fault. You no matter how much people
就像，我们无法控制。我们再也不想有这种感觉了。我们再也不想受到伤害了。这使得未来的关系变得非常非常困难。另一件大事是，我们不仅因为这些破碎的假设而发现很难信任他人，我们发现很难信任自己，我实际上认为这是更阴险的部分。虽然你可能理性地知道，我很乐意告诉你，每个人都可能告诉你这不是你的错。没有人要求被背叛。这根本不是你的错。无论人们
say like this came out of nowhere, this, we had no idea, there was no signs. Because your brain is trying to find all possible ways to avoid this from happening again, eventually it's going to turn that skepticism towards you and it's going to turn it into it's like it's looking for an answer eventually it's going to think am i the reason did i do something to deserve this is my intuition just all wrong do i just not know how to read people am i just stupid like eventually your brain it's normal it's going to think that none of that is true trust me you weren't stupid you didn't know really it's just not true this is just your brain trying to explore every possible solution. I get this question sometimes. I do manipulators know what they're doing. And the answer is,
怎么说，这就像凭空出现，我们不知道，没有任何迹象。因为你的大脑试图找到所有可能的方法来避免这种情况再次发生，最终它会把那种怀疑转向你，并把它变成它在寻找答案，最终它会想，我是原因吗？我做了什么值得这样吗？我的直觉完全错了吗？我只是不知道如何看人吗？我只是愚蠢吗？最终你的大脑，这是正常的，它会那样想，这些都不是真的，相信我，你并不愚蠢，你不知道，真的，这根本不是真的，这只是你的大脑试图探索每一个可能的解决方案。我有时会问这个问题。操纵者知道他们在做什么吗？答案是，
yes, they do. And even when they don't think they are being intentional about what they are doing, they are willingly and actively pushing down feelings of discomfort and guilt that any normal person would be able to read, understand that they are hurting somebody. And if they had a slice of empathy in them, turn away from. Right. Even that naivity, even that avoidance, even that ignorance that they may claim they have. That is still a sign that they are a manipulative person and that they had intention because at some point they ignored that feeling, the feeling that told them they were doing something wrong. I think that is just such clear evidence that this is not, was not, cannot be your fault. This is just sometimes how people operate with, they're just callous
是的，他们知道。即使当他们认为自己没有刻意去做他们正在做的事情时，他们也在自愿且积极地压制任何正常人都能读懂、理解他们正在伤害某人的不适感和内疚感。如果他们有一点同理心，就会转身离开。对吧。即使是那种天真，即使是那种回避，即使是他们可能声称自己拥有的那种无知。那仍然是一个迹象，表明他们是一个操纵性的人，他们有意图，因为在某个时刻，他们忽略了那种感觉，那种告诉他们正在做错事的感觉。我认为这只是如此明确的证据，表明这不是，不是，不可能是你的错。这只是有时人们运作的方式，他们只是冷酷
and they're cruel and there are people out there that are like that. I want to talk about this other strange psychological phenomena that often happens after betrayal. It's called called betrayal blindness. Jennifer Freid, she's a professor of psychology at the University of Oregon, and she's actually the founder and the CEO president, I guess, of the Center of Institutional Courage, basically talking about betrayal trauma. And she's done more extensive work on the impact of betrayal on the mind than probably any other human has, especially institutional betrayal, actually, and interpersonal betrayal. And through her research, she found that, that sometimes our mind protects us from seeing or processing betrayal early on in a relationship
而且他们很残忍，外面有那样的人。我想谈谈背叛后经常发生的另一种奇怪的心理现象。它被称为背叛盲视。詹妮弗·弗雷德，她是俄勒冈大学的心理学教授，她实际上是制度勇气中心的创始人兼首席执行官，我想是这样，基本上是在谈论背叛创伤。她对背叛对心灵的影响所做的广泛工作可能比任何其他人类都多，特别是制度性背叛，实际上，还有人际背叛。通过她的研究，她发现，有时我们的大脑会保护我们，不让我们在关系早期看到或处理背叛
or early on in our lives because to do so would be so disruptive that our mind almost willingly ignores it for us, which is why we then get that sense of like, shouldn't I have known? You literally couldn't have. Your brain was blocking you from knowing. An example of this might be with the parent abusing a child, right? This leaves the child in a terrible situation. They cannot speak up. They also cannot pull away because they have to engage in this relationship to have their basic needs met. And somebody might not listen to them and it will make it worse. This is why children or people sometimes experience betrayal blindness. They just don't even recognize that that was betrayal because to do so would mean they would have to leave or no longer
或者在我们生命早期，因为这样做会太具有破坏性，以至于我们的大脑几乎自愿为我们忽略它，这就是为什么我们随后会产生那种，我不应该知道吗？你实际上不可能知道。你的大脑在阻止你知道。这方面的一个例子可能是父母虐待孩子，对吧？这让孩子处于一种可怕的境地。他们无法说出来。他们也无法离开，因为他们必须参与这种关系才能满足他们的基本需求。而且有人可能不会听他们的，这会让情况变得更糟。这就是为什么孩子或人们有时会经历背叛盲视。他们甚至不承认那是背叛，因为这样做意味着他们必须离开或不再
have that bond. You know, it's different to when you're an adult or it's different to when you have a bit more control and you can confront somebody. You can do something. You can do something, hopefully, especially in these situations, if you're a grown child versus a young child, you could confront a partner who cheated on you. You could leave the relationship in some cases. Like, the problem arises with betrayal blindness when you don't have power, you're dependent on them, emotionally, financially, physically. Our response of withdrawal is the only one that we have. The only way that we can get through this is to be like, this is not happening. This is not occurring because I need my needs to be met and acknowledging betrayal would mean that I would have to live in.
拥有那种纽带。你知道，这与你成年时不同，或者与你有更多控制权并且可以面对某人时不同。你可以做点什么。你可以做点什么，希望如此，特别是在这些情况下，如果你是一个成年孩子而不是幼童，你可以面对欺骗你的伴侣。在某些情况下，你可以离开这段关系。就像，当你不拥有权力，你在情感、经济、身体上依赖他们时，背叛盲视的问题就会出现。我们的撤退反应是我们拥有的唯一反应。我们度过这一关的唯一方法就是表现得像，这没有发生。这没有发生，因为我需要满足我的需求，而承认背叛意味着我必须生活在。
That would be deeply dangerous for me. This would actually show up at work too. We might feel really neglected and betrayed by a boss, but because we rely on that job for financial security, like we don't want to rock the boat. Again, betrayal blindness. As a means of self-preservation, our brains literally may erase the experience in time. People have also been observed retelling the experience, and this is awful, but as if it's something they wanted, as if they were in control, when actually they weren't. It's something that their brain is doing to make them feel less, I hate this word, but like victimized. Sometimes enduring betrayal is about survival, and you cannot blame yourself for what you did to survive.
那对我来说将是非常危险的。这实际上也会出现在工作中。我们可能会感到被老板严重忽视和背叛，但因为我们依赖那份工作来获得经济保障，我们不想破坏现状。再说一次，背叛盲视。作为一种自我保护手段，我们的大脑实际上可能会随着时间的推移抹去这种经历。人们也被观察到在重述这种经历，这很糟糕，但就好像那是他们想要的东西，就好像他们有控制权，而实际上他们并没有。这是他们的大脑为了让他们感觉不那么，我讨厌这个词，但就像受害者一样所做的事情。有时忍受背叛是为了生存，你不能因为你为了生存所做的事情而责怪自己。
Like you just can't. What else were you meant to do? I want to talk about for a second to that last thing we spoke about just before that. Do manipulative people know they're manipulative or more specifically like what does it look like inside the mind of somebody who betrayed you? Like what is what's going on in there? This is such a common thing that comes up. Literally a week ago, less than a week ago, I was speaking to one of my friends about this and about a situation that they've been going through. and we were having this whole discussion of like, how could somebody do this to me? How, how?
就像你根本做不到。你还能做什么呢？我想花点时间谈谈我们刚才讨论的最后一件事。操纵型人格的人知道自己在操纵别人吗？或者更具体地说，背叛你的人内心世界是什么样的？他们脑子里在想什么？这是一个非常普遍的问题。就在一周前，不到一周前，我和一位朋友谈起这件事，谈到他们正在经历的情况。我们一直在讨论：一个人怎么能对我做这种事？怎么会？
We just kept coming back to it. And the thing is, like, you may never know because your mind operates in such a different way to them. You would never do anything like that. That's why you cannot empathize. The question, like, why would anybody do this requires empathy? It requires you to have some understanding of how that person's mind works. And in that moment, it's obvious that it works so differently that it's almost impossible to gain access to. The fact that you do not understand shows how differently you are as people and shows how much this was a them problem, not a you problem. But let's actually unpack some of the common reasons. The common reasons why people betray others that have nothing to do with the person themselves. Firstly, biggest explanation for betrayal, this person is just selfish.
我们一直在纠结这个问题。但事实是，你可能永远不会知道，因为你的思维方式和他们截然不同。你永远不会做那样的事，这就是为什么你无法产生共鸣。像“为什么有人会这么做”这样的问题需要同理心，需要你对那个人的思维方式有所了解。而那一刻，显而易见，他们的思维方式与你大相径庭，几乎无法理解。你无法理解这一事实恰恰说明了你们作为人有多么不同，也说明了这完全是他们的问题，而不是你的问题。但让我们来剖析一下人们背叛他人的常见原因，这些原因与受害者本人毫无关系。首先，背叛最主要的原因是：这个人就是自私。
There's a lot of self-interest in the world. People often betray others. to gain power, to gain attention, to gain money. They might also betray somebody to avoid negative consequences, to protect themselves from harm. In this instance, the betrayer has placed their own needs above the well-being of others. They might even feel justified. Like, you know, well, I'm not actually happy in that relationship. So, like, why not? Or, like, that person upset me this one time, so, like, I get one chance to get back at them.
世界上有很多利己主义。人们经常为了获得权力、关注或金钱而背叛他人。他们也可能为了逃避负面后果、保护自己免受伤害而背叛某人。在这种情况下，背叛者将自己的需求置于他人的福祉之上。他们甚至可能觉得自己有正当理由。比如，“我在这段关系中并不快乐，所以为什么不呢？”或者“那个人曾经让我不爽过一次，所以我可以趁机报复。”
This selfishness really stems from a sense of scarcity, like, or a sense of entitlement. that their needs are better and need to be more protected than yours. Next, insecurity. People commit acts of betrayal because they have low self-esteem. They might feel like they need to control or manipulate others to feel better about themselves, to avoid rejection, to earn a sense of validation that they so desperately need. Does this mean they deserve sympathy? That's up to you. You can decide because, I don't know, we all have insecurities. Most of us don't act. this way. I don't know. We all have insecurities and most of us don't cheat on our boyfriends. Most of us don't stab our friends in the back. The other thing is power dynamics. People,
这种自私实际上源于一种匮乏感或权利感，认为他们的需求比你的更重要，更需要被保护。其次是缺乏安全感。人们做出背叛行为是因为他们自尊心低。他们可能觉得需要控制或操纵他人来让自己感觉更好，以避免被拒绝，或者获得他们迫切需要的认可感。这是否意味着他们值得同情？这取决于你。你可以自己决定，因为我们都有不安全感，但我们大多数人不会这样做。我们都有不安全感，但我们大多数人不会背叛伴侣，也不会在背后捅朋友一刀。另一件事是权力动态。人们，
there are people who just want to assert power and they want to assert control. And this can occur in both a personal, professional, relationship setting. And it is a very serious, serious issue. You know, there are people who genuinely, yes, have a lack of empathy. Yes, are insecure. yes, have an inability to understand other people's feelings. And then they also kind of enjoy it. Like, they also, I've noticed this, get a kick out of cruel, controlling behavior. It's this strange thing. It's like they enjoy seeing the damage that they can do in other people's lives. It's exciting to them. these people exist and I think the reason why they do this is that the world feels uncontrollable to them, they feel insignificant, the world feels like it's been very unkind to them, so they rectify
有些人就是想主张权力和控制。这种情况可能发生在个人、职业或人际关系中。这是一个非常严重的问题。你知道，确实有些人缺乏同理心，确实缺乏安全感，确实无法理解他人的感受。而且他们甚至从中获得快感。我注意到，他们从残忍、控制的行为中得到满足。这很奇怪，他们似乎喜欢看到自己给别人的生活造成的破坏。这让他们感到兴奋。这些人确实存在，我认为他们这样做的原因是，世界对他们来说是不可控的，他们感到微不足道，觉得世界对他们很不友善，所以他们通过
that by messing in other people's lives to feel like God almost, to feel like they have a say in their destiny or their fate or the fate of other people. Like that's how they, that's how they go and do it, like totally, kind of totally off topic, not totally, but in a lot of science, psychological interviews with like serial killers or murderers. This is an explanation that I've seen a lot of them give. The justification that comes out in a lot of these manifestos and a lot of these interviews is like, I like it, I need to be in control. A lot of these men will be like as a child, as a kid, I felt like things just happened
干涉他人的生活来纠正这一点，让自己感觉像上帝一样，感觉自己能左右他人的命运。这就是他们行事的方式。这完全偏离了主题，也不完全是，但在许多针对连环杀手或谋杀犯的心理访谈中，这是很多人给出的解释。在许多宣言和访谈中，他们给出的理由是：“我喜欢这样，我需要掌控一切。”许多这样的人会说，小时候，我感觉事情只是发生
to me. That made me angry. So now it's my turn. It's my turn to make these bad things happen to other people. It's this weird universal karma. Pretty messed up. Pretty messed up. But again, shows that you are nothing like these people.
在我身上。这让我很生气。所以现在轮到我了。轮到我让这些坏事发生在别人身上了。这是一种奇怪的普遍业力。真是太糟糕了。但同样，这表明你和这些人完全不同。
It's good news, you can't understand them. It's just, I think that that lack of empathy shows that this is a personal flaw. Okay, we're going to take one more little itty-bitty short break here before we detail the recovery process from betrayal trauma and where to go from here. So without further ado, stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs. when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%,
这是好消息，你无法理解他们。我认为这种缺乏同理心恰恰说明这是一种个人缺陷。好了，在详细说明背叛创伤的恢复过程以及接下来该怎么做之前，我们要休息一下。所以，请继续收听。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯的情况下，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，
I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry.
我剖析了心理韧性、健身以及在这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家交谈，透过主导健康产业的那些不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学，看清真相。
We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
我们真的相信种子油本质上是促炎的。我们错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些磨难，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方搜索“2%”。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上拍了小金的胸部吗？或者坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人。
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84's big to me, not just because of crack.
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和小金有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一年，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何幸存下来的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的对话，大谈80年代的快克毒品。需要说明的是，84年对我来说很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。
I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed cracks. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really?
我愿意谈论快克，但只是想让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出其中有一条主线。我们现在还在讨论艾滋病。谢谢你帮我补全那句话。是的。我不认为还有比这更重要的黑人年份了。真的吗？
Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness, you know, your podcast, and in recognition of mental health awareness, this month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we
是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人，也是你们最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们
are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you can. You find it important to be a good person why you're here on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust.
已经拥有了它。我们还在追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们在盯着记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在活着的时候做一个好人很重要。你觉得在地球上做一个好人很重要吗？你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。那是两种不同层面的信任。
I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free, our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023,
我希望你真的能做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》中，我们进行关于治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你的免费iHeart Radio应用程序，搜索《Learn the Hardway》并立即收听。2023年，
former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in soons, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃卡德发现自己陷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了一场长达数年的法庭斗争，以证明真相。“你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吧？”“我伪造了一次测试。”这需要一支互联网侦探大军来破案。“我希望人们能看到他们的税款被用在了什么地方。”
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marincini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们揭露了一个令人不安的模式。另外两名经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·马林奇尼。“我的大脑被震撼了。”我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either.
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯因欺诈指控被起诉。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。第一条，永远不要招惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。第二条，也永远不要招惹她的朋友。
We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands.
我们总是说要相信你的女朋友。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《The Girlfriends》的新一季中……“天哪，这是同一个人。”一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过。“我觉得自己被卡车撞了。我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上？”警察似乎并不关心。所以她们采取了行动。
I said, oh, hell no. I vowed, I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Researchers have developed this thing that I think is incredibly helpful in situations like this and so good to cite in this episode called the betrayal grief cycle.
我说：“哦，见鬼，不。”我发誓，我将是他最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的。收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听。研究人员开发了一种我认为在这种情况下非常有帮助，并且在本集中非常值得引用的东西，叫做“背叛悲伤周期”。
And this is how they explain what you will feel at different stages of recovering from an act of betrayal. The one thing that they really emphasize, and we spoke about this in our Trauma Bond episode, if you listen to that one, go and listen to it after this, but betrayal doesn't eliminate grief. No matter how horrendous this person was, the good memories, they kind of still live. like a pleasant smell. And that can be really annoying at times, especially for interpersonal betrayal because there was, you know, it's hard because there was a time when everything was going really well. And when they said that they loved you and they cared about you and they were an amazing friend, they were a great parent, they were an amazing lover, grieving that is important.
这就是他们解释你在背叛行为恢复的不同阶段会感受到的东西。他们真正强调的一点是，我们在《创伤纽带》那一集中谈到过，如果你听过那一集，听完这集再去听听，但背叛并不能消除悲伤。无论这个人多么糟糕，美好的回忆依然存在，就像一种宜人的气味。这有时会非常令人恼火，尤其是对于人际背叛，因为……你知道，这很难，因为曾经有一段时间一切都很顺利。当他们说爱你、关心你，当他们是一个了不起的朋友、伟大的父母、出色的爱人时，哀悼这些是很重要的。
Your brain lived both experiences equally. It lived the experience of being hurt, but it also lived the experience of before that of feeling safe and that is still resonant in your mind. Because of that, healing from betrayal is so much like grief. And it does often follow the stages of grief that were first developed by Elizabeth Kubler-Ross that you've probably heard of before. But researchers have added a few extra stages in for betrayal trauma over, you know, grieving a dead person. So let's unpack these together because even if you've heard of these stages before, they do look a little bit differently, and they do even look a little bit differently from like the same cycle that's used for a breakup or used for a friendship fizzle,
你的大脑同样经历了这两种体验。它经历了受伤的体验，但也经历了之前感到安全的体验，这在你的脑海中依然回响。正因为如此，从背叛中治愈非常像悲伤。它通常遵循伊丽莎白·库伯勒-罗斯首次提出的悲伤阶段，你可能以前听说过。但研究人员在背叛创伤中增加了一些额外的阶段，超过了哀悼死者的阶段。所以让我们一起剖析这些阶段，因为即使你以前听说过这些阶段，它们看起来也略有不同，甚至与分手或友谊破裂所使用的周期看起来也略有不同，
or yeah, used for a death. So stage one is the same. I think anytime something deeply emotional happens, we react with shock. This is what you're going to have to go through first. We spoke about this earlier before, but there is horror at discovering what the betrayer has done, and we kind of just feel like numb. We are not really comprehending. We are not really comprehending. what happened, or maybe a little bit, but not fully and not deeply. Various studies have suggested that shock, actually, the reason we go through this is that it acts as like an emotional anesthetic. So basically, our brain is like, this is so intense. We cannot feel the full intensity of this. We can't feel this straight away. We will like, we will not survive.
或者用于死亡。所以第一阶段是一样的。我认为每当发生深刻的情感事件时，我们都会感到震惊。这是你首先要经历的。我们之前谈到过，发现背叛者所做的事情会感到恐惧，我们感觉麻木。我们并没有真正理解发生了什么，或者可能理解了一点，但并不全面，也不深刻。各种研究表明，震惊实际上是我们经历这个过程的原因，它就像一种情感麻醉剂。所以基本上，我们的大脑会说：“这太强烈了。我们无法感受到这种强度的全部。我们不能马上感受到。我们无法承受。”
So let's like numb us up so we can get through this and we can talk about it later. this is similar to like when people escape burning buildings with like their legs broken or like crazy things like that the shock delays the pain allowing you to behave in a life preserving way and the thing is is that this can last weeks this can last months sometimes it can last years you will move out of the shock phase when your brain finally thinks like oh they can handle it when they finally are like okay we have a little bit more coping going on which often sucks right because you kind of think that you've already lived through a little bit of it. And then suddenly when you actually are coping a little bit better, your brain's like, okay, cool, so we can give, we can give them the first dose now.
所以让我们麻木一下，这样我们就能度过难关，以后再谈。这类似于人们从燃烧的建筑物中逃生，腿骨折了或者类似疯狂的事情，震惊延迟了疼痛，让你以一种保全生命的方式行事。问题是，这可能会持续几周，几个月，有时甚至几年。当你最终认为“哦，他们能应付”时，你就会走出震惊阶段，当他们最终认为“好吧，我们有更多的应对机制”时，这通常很糟糕，对吧？因为你以为你已经经历了一点，然后突然当你真的应对得更好时，你的大脑会说：“好吧，酷，我们可以给他们第一剂了。”
Stage two is when this is really happening. So it's like the disbelief and the denial and also the first inching or tiny bit of pain. You start crying, panicking, start to feel hurt. There is still a sense, though, of like, it's going to be okay, right? Like, this is just a big prank. This was just an accident. This person didn't mean that. I heard them wrong. I got the wrong facts. Part of you still is feeling it, but wants to preserve the story you know so well, the story that people can be trusted. Stage three, that's when we get to obsession. This is the most confusing and painful stage. The rumination, the hunt for more information sets in, it becomes all-consuming. This is when also your brain starts to be like, maybe it was our fault.
第二阶段是真正发生的时候。所以就像怀疑和否认，还有最初的一点点疼痛。你开始哭泣、恐慌，开始感到受伤。然而，仍然有一种感觉，比如“会没事的，对吧？这只是一个恶作剧。这只是一个意外。这个人不是故意的。我听错了。我搞错了事实。”你的一部分仍然在感受它，但想要维护你所熟知的故事，那个人们值得信任的故事。第三阶段，那是我们陷入痴迷的时候。这是最令人困惑和痛苦的阶段。反刍，寻找更多信息的冲动开始了，它变得令人全神贯注。这也是你的大脑开始认为“也许是我们的错”的时候。
What could we have done to stop this from happening? This is when your brain starts to be like friends, family, like, what did you see? What do you know? Confirm, deny anything that you might have. Like, I need to know. It's a hunt. I would honestly say, especially if you've been cheated on, don't go hunting for more information. unless it's like absolutely necessary, like a legal case, like knowing too much about a betrayal
我们能做些什么来阻止这种情况发生？这是你的大脑开始询问朋友、家人“你看到了什么？你知道什么？确认、否认你可能有的任何东西。我需要知道。”这是一场狩猎。老实说，特别是如果你被背叛了，不要去寻找更多信息，除非绝对必要，比如法律案件。了解太多关于背叛的信息
might seem like it's going to make you feel better because it's going to offer closure. I think it actually just gives an already terrible situation even more detail. And that stuff can be really difficult to unsee. It can cause so much pain further on, or later on, I should say. It's up to you. Like some people do process better with more information, especially if it's like, institutional betrayal or like a workplace betrayal, it's like good to have your evidence and it's good to have things documented and to be like, oh, other people know and if there's like a legal case,
可能看起来会让你感觉更好，因为它会提供终结感。我认为它实际上只是给一个已经很糟糕的情况增加了更多的细节。而那些东西真的很难不去想。它可能会在以后造成更多的痛苦。这取决于你。有些人确实通过更多信息处理得更好，特别是如果是机构背叛或职场背叛，有证据、有记录、知道其他人也知道，如果有法律案件，
like that's very important. But especially for like interpersonal betrayal, at this stage, like the obsessional thoughts are normal. Try not to feed the beast. Stage four is anger and sadness. During stage four, you will find yourself furious, furious. Like, deeply deeply angry at the other person. I think this is a great sign. Congratulations. If you've gotten to the anger stage, congratulations. This is great because probably for the first half, you've been like, wow, this is just terrible. Everybody's sad. Everybody's hurt. Like, oh, like, maybe even making excuses and now you are like, I'm ready to fight. And like, that person shouldn't have done that to me. It's when you can see your sense of self-returning. You might also be angry at, like,
那非常重要。但特别是对于人际背叛，在这个阶段，强迫性的想法是正常的。尽量不要喂养这头野兽。第四阶段是愤怒和悲伤。在第四阶段，你会发现自己非常愤怒。就像对另一个人感到深深的愤怒。我认为这是一个很好的迹象。恭喜你。如果你已经到了愤怒阶段，恭喜你。这很好，因为可能在前一半时间里，你一直觉得“哇，这太糟糕了。每个人都很伤心。每个人都受伤了。也许还在找借口”，而现在你觉得“我准备好战斗了。那个人不应该那样对我。”这是当你能看到你的自我感回归的时候。你可能也会对
the person who told you what happened. Because you might see that as the source of betrayal, like shooting the messenger, if that's how you found out. You might be furious as well at this person for the transference of guilt, right? They alleviated their conscience by telling you. And so they've passed the guilt onto you like a little baton. Like, now it's your turn to carry this. They finally feel relieved. Weird sidebar.
告诉你发生了什么的人感到愤怒。因为你可能认为那是背叛的源头，就像“枪杀信使”，如果你是那样发现的话。你可能也会对这个人转移罪恶感感到愤怒，对吧？他们通过告诉你减轻了自己的良心。所以他们把罪恶感像接力棒一样传给了你。就像“现在轮到你背负这个了。”他们终于感到解脱了。奇怪的侧记。
if you guys remember the try guys, the YouTubers, and the guy, what was his name, Ned Forma, who, like, publicly cheated on his wife. He, like, did this whole YouTube video with her, maybe, like, six months ago when he was, like, oh, I'm going to, you know, I'm going to, yeah, did this whole YouTube video of, like, I'm going to launch this thing about people's rock bottoms,
如果你们还记得Try Guys，那些YouTuber，那个叫什么名字，内德·福尔马，他公开背叛了他的妻子。他大约六个月前和她一起拍了整个YouTube视频，当时他就像“哦，我要，你知道，我要……”做了整个YouTube视频，关于“我要发布这个关于人们跌入谷底的事情”，
and I'm going to interview my wife, who I cheated on for the first episode. And in it, she talks about the most, like, I love that she stole the spotlight. she talks about this moment when he told her when she could almost see relief in his eyes. Relief of like, thank God, I don't have to keep that in anymore. Thank God I can talk about this openly. And she talks about that moment of like, you took off like the backpack of your shame, of your mistakes, of your bad behavior and you were like, oh, can you carry that now?
我要采访我在第一集中背叛的妻子。在视频中，她谈到了最……我喜欢她抢了风头。她谈到了他告诉她时，她几乎能看到他眼中的解脱。那种“谢天谢地，我不用再隐瞒了。谢天谢地，我可以公开谈论这件事”的解脱。她谈到了那一刻，就像“你脱下了你的羞耻、你的错误、你的不良行为的背包，然后你说，‘哦，你能背着它吗？’”
Your term. And she had to keep it. Like that is an amazing way of describing it. and a describing of like how you suddenly realize and when you suddenly realize, oh, like, that was not a nice thing for you to do. And like, you were in the wrong. Stage five, when you hit stage five bargaining, you might find yourself really trying to, I think it's kind of like a slight reversal, right? If you can see, it's a lot of this is three steps forward, two steps back. This is another stage of like trying again to shove this experience
“轮到你了。”她不得不背着它。这真是一种描述它的绝妙方式。描述你如何突然意识到，当你突然意识到“哦，那不是你该做的好事。而且，你错了。”第五阶段，当你进入第五阶段讨价还价时，你可能会发现自己真的在尝试，我认为这有点像轻微的逆转，对吧？如果你能看到，这很多是进三步退两步。这是另一个阶段，试图再次将这种经历
into your worldview and bargaining about like, what if they only did it once? What if they didn't really know what they were doing? What if, what if I did give them a second chance? What if like I'm overreacting? Again, this is not a sign to like return to them or to prematurely forgive them. This is just how your brain is adjusting to the situation and trying to figure out the puzzle that is within you and trying to figure out the puzzle that is the situation and how to feel okay again. So it's totally normal to be bargaining before you end up in the final stage. Well, the second final stage of like the grieving process, which is mourning. You had anger, you had sadness, you had denial, bargaining, now it's just melancholy and just the deep anguish that comes with those
塞进你的世界观，并讨价还价，比如“如果他们只做了一次呢？如果他们真的不知道自己在做什么呢？如果我给了他们第二次机会呢？如果我反应过度了呢？”同样，这不是让你回到他们身边或过早原谅他们的信号。这只是你的大脑在适应这种情况，试图弄清楚你内心的谜题，试图弄清楚作为情况的谜题，以及如何再次感觉良好。所以在进入悲伤过程的最后阶段之前讨价还价是完全正常的。好吧，悲伤过程的第二个最后阶段是哀悼。你有愤怒，你有悲伤，你有否认，讨价还价，现在只是忧郁和随之而来的深深痛苦
shattered assumptions. You realize truly, like, how much you've lost. You realize you are, you're never going to get invited to those events with that person again. You're never going to have, you're never going to have the future of the wedding and the kids. You're, you're never going to get the job that you're never going to get an answer about that or never going to get your health back, the time back. Like, it's lost. You really lost out. the stage in the grief spaces is known as depression. And we can't understate how profound that really means, like what that really means.
破碎的假设。你真正意识到你失去了多少。你意识到你再也不会被邀请参加那个人的那些活动了。你再也不会有婚礼和孩子的未来了。你再也不会得到那份工作，再也不会得到关于那个问题的答案，或者再也不会找回你的健康、失去的时间。就像，它丢失了。你真的输了。悲伤空间中的这个阶段被称为抑郁。我们不能低估那意味着什么，那真正意味着什么。
All the adrenaline, all the investigating, all the thinking, the anger is taking a physical toll. And we will feel that. You might start to get sick a lot more often. You might start to really lose interest in everything that you would normally love. you might isolate as you mourn the end of this thing that you also feel equally like you shouldn't mourn because it ended so badly. It's really tough to adjust to the beginning of a new chapter. Like you didn't even want. You didn't want this chapter. Now you have to do your best with what
所有的肾上腺素、所有的调查、所有的思考、愤怒都在造成身体上的伤害。我们会感觉到。你可能会开始更频繁地生病。你可能会开始真正对你通常喜欢的一切失去兴趣。你可能会在哀悼这件事的结束时孤立自己，而你同时也觉得你不应该哀悼，因为它结束得太糟糕了。适应一个新篇章的开始真的很艰难。就像你甚至不想要这个篇章。你不想要这个篇章。现在你必须用你被给予的东西尽力而为，
you were given because you weren't given a choice. Morning is just like so hard. It's so uncomfortable. But I also think we tend to rush through it. And it's something that you cannot rush through. I think anybody who's experienced this will tell you like grief, sadness, heartbreak, betrayal are things that you have to move through rather than try and dodge around. And when you do, you get to stage seven, which is acceptance and recovery. I think the best way I've seen this described, how you know that you are like fully accepting what's happened to you is when the future starts to feel as exciting and good as you thought the past was. Basically, the before and the after start to feel similar. Like, there's optimism.
因为你没有选择。哀悼真的很难。它太不舒服了。但我认为我们往往急于度过它。这是你无法急于求成的事情。我想任何经历过这一点的人都会告诉你，悲伤、伤心、背叛是你必须经历而不是试图躲避的事情。当你这样做时，你就会进入第七阶段，即接受和恢复。我认为我见过的最好的描述方式，你怎么知道你已经完全接受了发生在你身上的事情，就是当未来开始感觉像你认为过去一样令人兴奋和美好时。基本上，之前和之后开始感觉相似。就像，有乐观情绪。
There's a deep sense of like, this is just what I was dealt. I can deal with it. I want to feel happy. I want to be alive. I want to get through this. How am I going to make this happen? Despite all of that. It's also probably the first time where you can like objectively see the situation for what it is. I think in the first few stages, there's always like a dominant emotion trying to convince you of some reality of this betrayal, you know, that it didn't happen, that it was all terrible, that you can never love again. And this is the moment when you just have a bit more neutrality. Not feeling nothing, but knowing that you felt everything, knowing more solidly that you weren't to blame, knowing more solidly their motivations and just being able to look at it just neutrally. again. Psychologists talk a lot about how in this stage it's really important to find meaning, right? There is another very famous guy, David Kessler. He wrote the book, You Can Heal Your Heart, which you may have read. He also wrote a lot of stuff on grieving, and he describes meaning when it comes to betrayal as how we learn to carry our grief and sadness differently rather than
有一种深深的感觉，比如“这就是我所经历的。我能应付。我想感到快乐。我想活着。我想度过难关。我该怎么做才能实现这一点？”尽管如此。这可能也是你第一次能客观地看待这种情况。我认为在最初的几个阶段，总有一种主导情绪试图让你相信这种背叛的某种现实，你知道，它没有发生，这一切都很糟糕，你再也不能爱了。这是你稍微多一点中立的时刻。不是什么都不感觉，而是知道你感受到了这一切，更坚定地知道你没有错，更坚定地知道他们的动机，并且能够再次中立地看待它。心理学家谈论很多关于在这个阶段找到意义的重要性，对吧？还有另一个非常有名的人，大卫·凯斯勒。他写了《你可以治愈你的心》这本书，你可能读过。他还写了很多关于悲伤的东西，他描述当涉及到背叛时，意义在于我们如何学习以不同的方式承载我们的悲伤和痛苦，而不是
eliminating it, finding a way to put all the individual heavy parts of grief and betrayal into a bag and carry it with us, maybe even put it down occasionally, maybe even forget it's there. It's basically how do we find a story that makes this make sense? Think of I was going to give any advice to someone going through betrayal. It would be this. Whatever makes the story of this moment relevant or makes sense to you, grasp onto that. Whatever story, whether that is the story that everything happens for a reason, whether it is the story of rejection is redirection, whether it is the story of karma,
消除它，找到一种方法把悲伤和背叛的所有沉重部分放进一个袋子里随身携带，甚至偶尔放下它，甚至忘记它的存在。基本上，我们如何找到一个让这一切变得合理的故事？我想如果我要给任何经历背叛的人建议。我会是这样。无论什么让这一刻的故事变得相关或对你有意义，抓住它。无论什么故事，无论是“一切发生皆有原因”的故事，还是“拒绝就是重定向”的故事，还是业力的故事，
whether it is the story of how this will allow you to help others in the future, the story that this is proof of your own capacity to love, whatever it is, find the story that makes this make sense, if you can. Like find something that allows you to take those shattered assumptions and be like, hearing new assumptions, and they feel just as comfortable. Finally, just remember, even though it was done to you, it wasn't about you. I cannot stress this enough. I have a friend going through this at the moment, and the thing we keep discussing is this person
还是“这将使你在未来帮助他人”的故事，还是“这是你自身爱人能力的证明”的故事，无论它是什么，找到让这一切变得合理的故事，如果可以的话。就像找到一些东西，让你能够把那些破碎的假设拿走，然后说：“听着，新的假设，它们感觉同样舒服。”最后，记住，即使它是对你做的，它也不是关于你的。我怎么强调都不为过。我有一个朋友目前正在经历这个，我们一直在讨论的事情是这个人
isn't going to magically become a different version of themselves for whoever comes next, or for their next best friend, or for their next partner, or for their next employee, or for their next whatever. Like, they're not going to magically change. This is a part of their character. And even if they do, even if they do get help and they do change, whatever they do next doesn't erase the pain they caused in the past. It doesn't suddenly erase this part of their history. Like, just because they're a great person doesn't mean that, like, they've always been that way.
不会神奇地为下一个到来的人，或者为他们的下一个最好的朋友，或者为他们的下一个伴侣，或者为他们的下一个员工，或者为他们的下一个什么人，变成一个不同版本的自己。他们不会神奇地改变。这是他们性格的一部分。即使他们确实改变了，即使他们确实得到了帮助并且他们确实改变了，他们接下来做的任何事情都不能抹去他们在过去造成的痛苦。它不会突然抹去他们历史的这一部分。就像，仅仅因为他们是一个好人并不意味着他们一直都是那样。
The fact that they betrayed you is just as much a part of their story as it is of yours. They will always be a part of them that knows. There will always be a part of them that did that act, like, that had the capacity to do that. So I want to wrap up this episode by just saying, by just saying like, don't think that you as a victim of this betrayal were somehow, and I know this is going to sound weird, were somehow special. It is them through and through. It, like, the people have the capacity to do this. It's something in them just really, again, that quote from the beginning saw your needs, saw the respect that you were owed and decided. that's just not as important as my own interests and went ahead with that.
他们背叛你的事实和你故事的一部分一样，也是他们故事的一部分。他们永远会有一部分知道。他们永远会有一部分做了那个行为，有能力做那个行为。所以我想通过说，通过说“不要认为作为这次背叛的受害者，你以某种方式——我知道这听起来很奇怪——以某种方式很特别”来结束这一集。这完全是他们的问题。人们有能力做这件事。这在他们身上，真的，再次引用开头的那句话，看到了你的需求，看到了你应得的尊重，然后决定
That is a completely them situation. I know a lot of this is just like lingo and words and like whatever, psychobabble theories, and sometimes like that cannot erase the pain of what you're going through. But I do hope the psychoeducation and the more scientific perspective on what you're experiencing can neutralize some of the shame and neutralize. some of like the grief by showing you that like not that this is a normal experience but this is like there are things to this experience that every a human would go through and that every a human would feel pain by because they are so devastating and you are no different it's also something that like
那不如我自己的利益重要，然后就那样做了。那完全是他们的情况。我知道很多这只是行话和词汇，什么心理学理论，有时这无法抹去你正在经历的痛苦。但我确实希望心理教育和对你所经历的事情的更科学的视角可以中和一些羞耻感，中和一些悲伤，通过向你展示这不是一种正常的经历，但这种经历中有一些每个人都会经历的事情，每个人都会因为这些事情而感到痛苦，因为它们太具有破坏性了，你也不例外。这也是一些像
I don't know time maybe won't heal but does wonders for and I think the fact that you are moving through this with grace you are looking to learn you are looking to understand yourself better through the actions of somebody else is really, really powerful stuff. And I think that there is a lot of healing and amazing things coming your way. I really do believe it. I really do believe that for every terrible person or terrible institution or terrible situation out there, there is like something equally as gorgeous and wonderful. And I think that you are 100% deserving of it and it is on its way to you. So thank you again for listening. Thank you, as always to our researcher Lucy Davidson for her assistance with this episode.
我不知道时间也许不会治愈，但会创造奇迹的事情，我认为你正在优雅地度过这个难关，你正在寻求学习，你正在通过别人的行为更好地了解自己，这真的很强大。我认为有很多治愈和令人惊奇的事情正在向你走来。我真的相信。我真的相信，对于每一个糟糕的人、糟糕的机构或糟糕的情况，都有同样华丽和美妙的东西。我认为你100%值得拥有它，它正在向你走来。所以再次感谢你的收听。一如既往地感谢我们的研究员露西·戴维森对本集的协助。
make sure that if you enjoyed this episode and you are listening to maybe go and check us out on Netflix. That is right. We now have episodes on Netflix, episodes just like this one, wherever you are in the world. Go and check it out. You can also follow us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast if you feel called to do so. If you want to contribute to episodes like this, we often have question boxes go up. We often look for listener stories that inform episodes just like this one. So it's a great opportunity to get involved. And yeah, there's all these other links. There's all these other things that you can access.
确保如果你喜欢这一集，并且你正在收听，也许去Netflix上看看我们。没错。我们现在在Netflix上有剧集，就像这一集一样的剧集，无论你在世界的哪个角落。去看看吧。如果你觉得有必要，你也可以在Instagram上关注我们@ThatPsychologyPodcast。如果你想为像这样的剧集做出贡献，我们经常会有问题箱。我们经常寻找为像这样的剧集提供信息的听众故事。所以这是一个参与的好机会。是的，还有所有这些其他链接。还有所有这些你可以访问的其他东西。
I will just leave them in the description down below. But until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilient.
我会把它们留在下面的描述中。但直到下次，保持安全，保持善良，对自己温柔。我们很快就会再谈。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯的情况下，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。我在我的播客《2%》中。我剖析了心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。
in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast.
在我们奇怪的现代世界中。让自己经历一些磨难，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方搜索“2%”。在《Look Back at it》播客中。
From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors.
从1979年开始，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一年，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图与我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行和最喜欢的作家一起理解我们是如何幸存下来的。
Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to learn the hard way
就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。那是一个疯狂的年份。那是一个疯狂的年份。我不认为还有比这更重要的黑人年份了。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？你们正在收听《Learn the Hard Way》
with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast,
和你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，在任何地方进行这些对话都不安全，但你正在与一位知道自己在做什么的持牌专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcast上收听《Learn the Hard Way》，
or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hope. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
或任何你获取播客的地方。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃卡德被指控生下双胞胎。但怀孕似乎是一个骗局。“你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，欧文斯女士，对吧？”“我伪造了一次测试。”这需要一支互联网侦探大军来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两名经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋者。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you. you get your podcasts.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。“我的大脑被震撼了。”我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。
When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们采取了行动。“我发誓，我将是他最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。”我们总是说要相信你的女朋友。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。
This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一个iHeart播客。保证是人类制作的。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。